hi in this module i'm going to formally
define constraint satisfaction problems
and the more general notion of a factor
graph
so let's begin with an example a voting
example so let's imagine there are three
people
person one person two and person three
and each one is going to cast the vote
either blue or red blue red
blue or red and we know something about
these people we know that person one is
definitely going to vote blue here and
we know that person three is gonna is
leaning red
we also know that person one and person
two are really close friends so they
must agree on their vote whereas person
two and person three are mere
acquaintances and their votes only tend
to agree
so the question is um how are all these
people going to influence each other and
ultimately cast votes
so we can model this problem using a
factor graph
we're going to define
a set of variables x1 for person 1 x2
for person 2 x3 for person three
and we're going to define a set of
factors that capture each of these four
uh constraints or preferences
so let's begin with f1 f1 is going to
capture the fact that person 1 is
definitely blue
so
i'm going to write f1 as
specifying as a table specifying for
each value
of x1
i'm going to specify a number so f1 of
x1
is going to be 0 if x1 is red and it's
going to be 1 if x1 is b
or blue
and this captures the fact that
0 means
no way this is going to happen and 1
means it's ok
so mathematically i can write this
factor f1 as
an indicator function of x1 equals b
so now i'm going to write these
indicator functions without
usually you would write a 1 here on
because it's just going to drop it
for notational simplicity
so let's look at
leaning red so this factor is going to
be x f4 and this is also going to
correspond to a table where for every
possible value of x3
um i'm going to specify a value so r is
going to be 2 and b is going to be 1.
and mathematically this is going to be
f4 is equal to x3 equals r this
indicator a function plus the smoothing
constant of 1. so remember this
indicator is going to return one or zero
depending on whether it's condition is
true or false and i'm adding one so i
offset that to a two or a one
so intuitively you can think about this
as person three
prefers
r to be maybe twice as much
so now let's look at these other factors
so f2 is going to
represent the fact that person 1 and
person 2 have to agree
so again i'm going to look at all the
possible assignments to the variables in
the scope of
f2 so these two variables x1 x2
and for every value i'm going to assign
a particular non-negative number so here
um rr i'm going to say that's one it's
okay they agree and if they don't agree
i'm going to return 0 because i really
don't like that and
if they return b that's agree so that's
a 1.
so more succinctly i can write this
factor as f2 as
x1 equals x2
and now finally
for f3 f3 is going to capture whether x2
and x3 tend to agree
and this table is going to look like
this for x2 and x3
if they're both r i'm going to return 3
if they're different i'm going to return
2
and if they're all both b then i'm going
to return 3.
so mathematically
this factor is going to be
indicated function of whether x2 equals
x3
plus a smoothing factor of 2
which makes it
instead of 1 0 0 1 that gives me 3 2 2
3.
so there's a kind of a mild preference
for these two people to agree compared
to not agree
so now if you click on this demo in the
slides here this is going to take you to
a little javascript application here
where you can actually write your own
fact graph
and we're going to come back to this um
later
so this is the first example of a factor
graph capturing this simple voting
situation
so now let's look at a different example
that we looked at the overview module so
this is map colony australia so remember
australia has these
seven beautiful provinces and each one
needs to be assigned a color
so each of these provinces is going to
be represented as a variable
and here i'm going to give every
variable a name um wa for western
australia nt for northern territory and
so on and i'm going to use big x usually
to denote the set of all variables
each variable is also going to take on
a set of values
which in this case is going to be red
green or blue
and now i'm going to define the factors
of this factor graph
so for every two neighboring provinces i
want to say that they can't have the
same color
so for example f1 is going to say wa and
nt must be different
that corresponds to this
factor over here
f2 says ntnq must be different
and that's going to correspond to this
factor here
and so on and so forth
so now we're ready to formally define a
factor graph so a factor graph
is uh going to consist of a set of
variables um x1 through xn in the
general case remember big x is going to
denote the set of all variables
where each variable x i
takes on values in some set of possible
values known as the domain of variable i
and a factor graph also consists of a
set of factors
generally denoted f1 through fm
each fj is going to be a function
that takes on um takes as input an
assignment
to the variables and going to represent
uh represent a return of a non-negative
number so it's really important that
this function return a non-negative
number instead of a negative number
because later we'll see that we're going
to multiply them
together
so that's the definition of a factor
graph
so a bit of terminology here um so
i'm going to define the scope of a
factor
as the set of factors as a set of
variables it depends on
so in the map coloring example
the scope of f1
is going to be
simply um wa and nt
this corresponds to visually the set of
variables that this
this factor is touching
um the arity of a factor is number of
variables in the scope
so in this case you just count how many
variables are here the answer is two
um some shorthand notation so unary
factors are ones that have area 1 and
binary factors are ones that have error
d2
and constraints are factors that return
0 or 1.
so notice that factor can return any
non-negative number but a special case
is when it returns 0 1 which means yes
or no essentially
and in this context
f1 is a binary
constraint so one thing to remember
about factors is
that each factor usually depends only on
a
subset of the variables
and not all the variables and this is
going to be kind of important when we
talk about an algorithmic efficiency
so now we fully define
what a factor graph is
i'm going to now talk about the notion
of assignment weight
so let's go back to the voting example
in the voting example we had a four
factors corresponding to whether
person one and person three were voting
a certain way and whether person one
person two and person two and person
three are agreed or not
um so an assignment
is going to be um just
um assignment of values to each of the
the variables in this case there's three
variables x1 x2 x3
and each assignment is going to be
associated with a weight
so here's how the weight is going to be
calculated i'm going to go through each
of these factors and i'm going to plug
in this assignment and read out a
particular number
so let's take this factor f1
so what is x1 it's r
so i'm going to get a zero
what about this factor what is x1 and x2
it's going to rr i'm going to return a
1. let me copy that down here well this
factor x2 and x3 are rr i'm going to get
a 3
and finally the fourth factor f4
what is x3 it's r so i'm going to read
out a 2.
and the
all these uh the outputs of the factors
are numbers i'm going to multiply all of
them together i'm going to get a weight
and that weight in this case is 0. so
now you can go through all the other
possible assignments of values to all
the variables
in this case there are eight possible
assignments
and each of them is going to have a
particular weight
so now let's look at the demo um if you
click step here that's going to run this
inference algorithm and produce
a wait for
every possible
assignment that's um that has non-zero
weight so in this case we verify that
there is two possible
um assignments
that have non-zero weight
assigning bbr and
bbb
okay so now let's switch over again to
the map coloring example just to see how
weights are computed here
so here is a possible
assignment
and
of course to provinces
so here
notationally i'm going to make a slight
change it's going to be sometimes
convenient to be representing
assignments in this kind of dictionary
format where
the variables have names
so here
i have
wa is assigned red
nt assigned time green and so on and so
forth so literally you can think about
this as a python dictionary if you like
what is the weight of this assignment
well in this particular case
all
neighbors
have different colors
and remember the each factor is just
going to thumbs up
return one if
the two adjacent neighbors have this
different colors so i'm just gonna get
one times one times one and that's just
one
now consider alternative assignment
where i've simply replaced nt
with red here so nt it becomes red
and now we can see that the weight of
this altered assignment is going to be
zero because these two factors are going
to evaluate to zero
these two here
and one thing you might realize very
quickly here is that
all it takes is for one
factor to veto
the entire assignment because we're
multiplying if one of the factors
returns zero
then the product of all the factors is
also going to be zero
so here is a general definition of
assignment weight
assignment little x
is going to be x1 through xn
has a weight
um
and this weight
uh
is a function that takes an assignment
and returns
the product over all possible factors
of
the factor f j
apply to
an assignment
and here no even though
each factor only depends on the subset
of variables i'm i'm kind of simplifying
notation by just passing in an entire
assignment in practice i would only pass
in only the variables that are in the
scope of fj
so a bit of terminology an assignment is
consistent
if its weight is greater than
um
zero
weight can't be negative because all the
factors return non-negative numbers so a
weight is zero
that means the assignment is
inconsistent
and the objective of a constrained
satisfaction problem finally getting to
what the point of all this is is to find
the maximum weight assignment
mathematically it's written arc max over
all possible assignments x of weight of
x
and a constraint satisfaction problem is
said to be satisfiable
if
the weight of a maximum weight
assignment is greater than zero
another way to say the same thing is
whether there exists some consistent
assignment
and
note one thing is that the weight here
in the context of factor graphs and
constraint satisfaction problems
are
not the same as a weight in that we
study in machine learning those weights
can be negative or non-negative um but
these weights and concerns satisfaction
problems and factor graphs have to be
non-negative
one other
small comment is that here we are
actually defining a slight
generalization of constraint
satisfaction problems where factors can
actually
um
have not just zero or one
weights uh but actually
any non-negative value
so constraint satisfaction problems um
actually is a general umbrella term that
captures several important
cases
so the first is boolean satisfiability
problems otherwise known as sat so in
these cases um the variables are boolean
valued and the factors are a logical
formula such as x1 or not x2 or x5
so satisfiability problems are
become mp complete problems which means
that in the worst case they're really
really hard and we don't have efficient
algorithms for solving them
but
in practice
it turns out that we've there's been an
extraordinary amount of progress in set
solving
and we can actually routinely solve us
sad problems with many many more
variables than we might be able to
predict uh by theory alone
so there's a joke that says you know
theoreticians reduce a problem to set if
they want to show that it's a hard to
solve and practitioners reduce a problem
to set if they want to solve the problem
another class of problems that are is
important is linear programming and this
in linear programs the variables are
real valued numbers and the factors are
a linear inequality such as x2 plus x3
x5 less than or equal to one
and despite the fact that variables can
take on an infinite number of values
linear programs have the special
structure that makes them especially
efficient to solve and there's been a
lot of work in
solving linear programs efficiently
integer linear programs are same as
linear programs except for
the variables are integer valued
and this is the fact that they're
integer values makes these incredibly
hard again just like satisfiability
problems mixed interior linear programs
are
um are problems where variables are
reals and integers
um and these problems are also hard to
solve
so in summary
we formally defined the notion of a
factor graph which includes variables
and
factors so variables specify
unknown quantities that we need to
ascertain
and factors specify
preferences or constraints for partial
assignments
and one thing
that's special about factor graphs is
that you're specifying constraints and
preferences in a local way
so suppose you're modeling
and
you think of a particular preference
that you have you can just simply write
down a factor
in terms of the variables that are that
matter and throw that factor into the
constraint satisfactoring problem
and now the hard work comes in actually
processing all these set of factors
so a key definition is the weight of a
possible an assignment
is the product of all the factors and
this is where all the magic happens this
is where
the
you have to think globally about all the
factors together
and
the point of a constraint satisfaction
problem again is to find the maximum
weight assignment and this is again
something that requires global reasoning
over all the factors
and so the model here to remember is
specify locally if you're modeling and
optimize globally which is what the
inference algorithm will do
that's the end of this module
you